on Tuesday the Trump Department of
Justice announced they would move to
combat the racism inherent in college
admissions affirmative action instead of
using the DOJ Civil Rights Division as a
sort of defense mechanism for radical
leftist groups as the Obama
administration did the Trump
administration is going to use the
office to crack down on actual
discrimination pursuing what they call
investigations and possible litigation
related to intentional race-based
discrimination in college and university
admissions according to an internal
document this is a welcome development
despite the left's quick move to
demagogue the issue by claiming this is
somehow white identity politics defense
mechanism from the Trump administration
often the group's hurt most by
affirmative action are not white people
but minorities like Asian Americans and
Jews the left of course complains the
DOJ Civil Rights Division should be
specifically dedicated to the interests
of particular minorities as Kristen
Clark of the lawyers Committee for civil
rights under law told the New York Times
the left thinks the civil rights
division was quote created and launched
to deal with the unique problem of
discrimination faced by our nation's
most oppressed minority groups she
called the move deeply disturbing called
it a dog whistle that's ridiculous
first off affirmative action has done
nothing to advance black economic
interests according to Steven and
Abigail Fernstrom of the liberal
Brookings Institute quote not only did
significant advances predate the
affirmative action era the benefits of
race conscious politics are not clear in
a decade since affirmative action
policies were first instituted the
poverty rate has remained basically
unchanged despite black gains by
numerous other measures close to 30
percent of black families still live
below the poverty line in fact very
often those who make it into the top
universities through affirmative action
are themselves hurt by the process let's
say a black student performed well
enough to get into Duke but not Yale
putting that student at Yale means that
instead of flourishing an environment in
which the student has earned membership
that student will now be low man on the
totem pole in an article published in
the Atlantic in 2012 Richard standard
and Stuart Taylor jr. highlight some of
the ways this mismatch issue impacts
black students mismatched students
students who got in through significant
affirmative action they're twice as
likely to be derailed from pursuing a
doctorate and an academic career black
law school grads are four times as
likely to fail the bar as the white
counterparts black college freshmen
wants to go into science or engineering
more than white students but are twice
as likely to drop out about half of
black college students rank in the
bottom 20% of their classes and the
bottom 10% in law school and of course
the permit of action is unfair to those
of other
races who outperform the minorities who
benefit a Princeton University studies
showed that blacks received a bonus of
230 points on SAT scores versus their
competitors on the old 1600 point scale
by contrast Asians were penalized 50
points so this isn't the dog whistle
it's a solid policy aimed at ending the
sort of discrimination that continues to
divide us by race assuming without
evidence that a black kid who scores
lower on the SATs than an Asian kid of
the same socioeconomic status had
somehow suffered more and requires the
Open University slot that's precious
it's nasty and it should be fought good
for the Trump administration i'm ben
shapiro this is the venture puro show
[Music]
already so a lot to get to today as
always want to talk about President
Trump apparently opening me Seth rich
can of worms just a little bit but the
biggest story in the news is obviously
what's going on in Venezuela where
socialism has collapsed as it always
does into a full-scale disaster going to
talk about that in just a second but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at helix lead so as I
mentioned before I am world's crappiest
sleeper I'm not good at sleeping or we
saw it wasn't until we got the helix
Sleep mattress so helix sleep is this
fantastic service of what you go to
their website over at helix sweet comm
slash bed and you answer a few simple
questions and then they run your answers
through a customized algorithm to get
you the sort of mattress that you need
and you can get a mattress that is
different on both sides of the bed for
you and your spouse if they send it
right to your door you open up the box
you open up the plastic and boom the
thing inflates right in front of you
because it is a foam mattress and it is
supremely comfortable and it is
customized to you Heelys customers
report a 30% improvement in overall
sleep quality your mattress arrives at
your door in about a week shipping is
100% free and you have a hundred nights
to try it out so if you don't like it
they'll pick it up for free and give you
a 100% refund no questions asked so
really is a no lose proposition plus the
mattresses like this are more
inexpensive than mattresses of
comparable quality from other places go
to helix sleep comm slash Ben get $50
off your order that helix sleep comm
slash Ben helix sleep comm / Ben a
mattress is something you really should
spend the money on you're on it every
single night and your quality of sleep
is going to make a difference in your
life it has for me helix sleep comm /
Ben to get $50 off your first order and
it lets them know that we sent you as
well so it helps out the show okay so
latest from Venezuela is that there is
total chaos total cast is broken out in
Venezuela in the last in the last three
days
ten people opposition people have been
killed opposition to the socialist
dictator Nicolas Maduro who was the guy
who took over for Google Chavez ten
people were killed on Sunday there was a
referendum or an election for a
Constituent Assembly and this means in
Venezuela they want to replace basically
the legislature with this new
legislature run by the dictator that's
essentially why all the opposition
boycotted and and you can see how awful
everything is in Venezuela here last
night
Maduro went and had his police arrest
the two main opposition leaders here's
tape of that 22 okay so they took away
Ledesma they also took away a guy named
Leopoldo Lopez these are both leaders of
the Democratic opposition to the
socialist regime in Venezuela on Sunday
there are riots in Venezuela in the
middle of the election because the
opposition was protesting and ten people
were killed here some of the video from
the riots Election Day erupted again
into violent clashes between
anti-government protesters and the
National Police
the opposition did all it could to block
roads to polling stations and otherwise
disrupt the voting they see president
nicolas maduro effort to rewrite the
Constitution as yet another power grab
nope no possum there are people who
think this is a step towards
dictatorship what do you think that's oh
no no not about that said this man we
were in a dictatorship okay so the
president went to vote early and called
this the most important vote in the
nation's history a move to restore law
and order he said and he thumbed his
nose at international opposition to the
vote the US is among those threatening
further sanctions
seaton orally has an elite if you do not
decide who decides for you he said
Donald Trump if you the Venezuelan
people do not decide who will the son in
some pro Maduro areas voting was largely
uneventful but in the streets over the
past four months more than 100 people
have been killed at least two today in
violent skirmishes we my my chair it's
important to note here that Venezuela is
one of the most natural resource rich
countries in the Western Hemisphere and
they have enormous natural resources
their oil reserves are the largest in
the Western Hemisphere and they are they
were an incredibly rich country I mean
into the 90s they were the richest
country in South America Lugo Chavez
took over he immediately began
redistributionist programs shall explain
in a moment and why this is important
for the United States and he immediately
sank the country into absolute poverty
here's some video from Venezuelan food
lines people have now been reduced to
searching through garbage I have friend
named Ami Horowitz went down there did a
report from there he watched his
cameramen be shot to death Caracas is
the most is the most violent city in the
Western Hemisphere it again this was one
of the wealthiest countries in the
Western Hemisphere it's just like Cuba
these were these wealthy growing
economies and they've been absolutely
destroyed by socialism there are people
now who are who are searching through
the trash when Amy was there he told me
that he was watching normal citizens
hunting dogs to eat in the streets like
stray dogs hunting them down killing
them and eating them here's some video
from CNN of some of the food lines again
this is the capital city of what was one
of the great countries in the Western
even in the driving rain Venezuelans
started their day in search of food
expecting to see the usual grim queues
that form at government stores not today
the only stores with affordable food are
shut closed for the national workers
holiday the sign explained it said sorry
and thank you people walked away
empty-handed but full of dread wondering
where their next meal might come from I
asked Julian Perez what he need Oh Paul
illogical all the basics well I have
nothing at home I say sometimes I go
hungry who can say that we the people
who are hungry right now and here's the
thing if people aren't allowed to come
back tomorrow
food is rationed here doled out
according to the last number on your
government ID carlos salinas explains
his turn is today his number is fine I'm
single or nickles I mean things bad is
happening to modern country we can all
see the tape of it okay and this is
happening because of socialism this is
happening because of leftism one who go
Chavez to power he took power saying and
there were these rich oligarchs who are
running the country now the oil industry
had already been nationalized in
Venezuela but Google Chavez did is he
grabbed up all of the foreign owned
drill drilling facilities and all of the
sites he grabbed all the stuff he
nationalized those men he used all the
money supposedly to redistribute but
really was to enshrine his own
dictatorship he paid off all of his
supporters he made sure that if you were
not one of his supporters you couldn't
get a job
he ran people out of jobs he set up
these neighborhood councils that were
theoretically supposed to redistribute
property he seized a thousand different
plots of land all over the country for
redistribution they were never
redistributed even when they were
redistributed it was very often to
people who didn't know what they were
doing so what you ended up with was a
dramatic drop-off in all the productive
capacity of the country which prompted
him to ratchet up tariffs right he said
okay well if we can't produce anything
in the country and we're getting and
we're buying everything from out of the
country will ratchet up the tariffs
which meant that no one could afford
anything so nothing was being imported
and nothing was being produced so nobody
actually had either the money to buy
anything or the productive capacity to
make anything he created wage controls
he created price controls he ramped up
the inflate
entirely destroyed the economy I mean
entirely destroyed it to the point where
you're seeing people literally searching
through the garbage at breadlines I mean
not just at government breadlines
they'll go to bakeries and this is
according to the Associated Press Hanna
Dreyer of The Associated Press reporting
today quote the government of President
Nicolas Maduro blames the u.s. and
right-wing business interests for the
economic collapse but most economists
say it actually stems from the
government imposed price and currency
distortions of course the United States
can't even trade with Venezuela because
of Google Chavez and mrs. Nicolas Maduro
there often seems to be a direct line
she writes between economic policy and
daily hardship one week the
administration's accredited eggs would
now be sold for no more than 30 cents a
carton the next week eggs had
disappeared from supermarkets and still
have not come back people started
digging through the trash at all hours
pulling out vegetable peelings soggy
pizza crusts eating them on the spot
that seemed like rock bottom until my
local bakery started organizing lines
each morning not to buy bread but to eat
trash okay that's what's going on in
Venezuela right now and this is what
happens when you have a government that
is completely dedicated to the notion of
eradicating income inequality the reason
I say that is that between 2000 well
Chavez took over 1999 between 1999 and
2013 when Chavez died the income
inequality
in Venezuela dropped dramatically it's a
crap hole okay it was the second least
income equal unequal country in the
Western Hemisphere after Canada did it
matter to these people who are starving
on the streets of course not because one
way that you create income equality is
by destroying the economy Sudan has a
lot of income equality you know why
there's no one rich there because
garbage country okay it's run like
garbage so this is what happens in
Venezuela you have now more income
equality
unfortunately everybody's poor and
digging through the garbage in order to
get out of this they've now created
hyperinflation they're trying to inflate
their way out they've taken out loans
and loans and loans and loans and trying
to pay those back inflating their
currency now in the last week okay you
ready for this on Friday
one dollar equals ten thousand three
hundred eighty nine bolivars bolivars
are there mend after simón bolívar c mon
Bulevar it's that's their form of
currency ten thousand three hundred
eighty nine bolivars is one dollar or on
Monday on Monday you know five days
before it was worth eight thousand eight
hundred and twenty bolivars at the start
of the year one dollar equaled 3164
bolivars
okay so that means the day of the
increased inflation by 300%
in the course of six months again that
is why you are seeing people who can't
buy anything your savings are worth
nothing you spend your entire life
saving up building up a business putting
that money in the bank and now your
savings are worth nothing they are worth
nothing okay and for all the talk of you
know they did they've absolutely
eradicated poverty they've not
eradicated poverty look at this country
this is well as a country that's
eradicated poverty in fact is there
hospitals don't have gloves don't have
soap don't have doctors ten thousand
doctors have left the country no one can
make a living here this is what happens
when you have a country that is solely
dedicated to the proposition the
dictatorship the demagogues I mean it's
Bernie Sanders gland okay this is this
is winning demagogue and you say it's
big business that's doing all of this
all we have to do is seize all the
property from big businesses and
redistribute it or regulated so deeply
that we ensure that we spread around all
the love now I think that we should not
allow the left to get away with this
because one of the left did is for
literally years for literally years they
talked about how wonderful Chavez was
how wonderful Chavez ISM was how great
we'll go travel to nicolas maduro war
it's amazing you know we on the right
are criticized very often for the war in
Iraq how many evil countries has left it
declared were good before they actually
turned evil the left actually liked Nazi
Germany until it turned out that Hitler
was Hitler let's elect Mussolini and
turned out that Mussolini was Mussolini
the left like Lenin until it turned out
that Lenin and Stalin were Lenin and
Stalin the left like Mao until it turned
out that Mao was now the left like
Google Chavez and turned out until it
turned out that Google Chavez oogo
Chavez in each time each time leftist
dictatorship is tried every single time
the left immediately declares after it
fails it wasn't honestly tried socialism
never been honestly tried is really
funny today I tweeted out that the world
bank calls Venezuela one of the most
income equal states on earth and the
Socialist Party if that's the official
Socialist Party tweeted it me and they
said how dare you blame socialism for
this really this is what they tweet it
okay I'm gonna read it to you Venezuela
is what happens when leftism goes wrong
don't blame socialism for a leftist
failure to manage a profit-driven
capitalist economy so in their opinion
if they just nationalized all the
resources over at the Socialist Party if
they nationalize even more it would go
even better and then they attached a
graphic that said question which
countries have tried socialism answer
with populations collectively and
directly owning the means of production
and distribution therefore resulting in
free access
all goods and services none socialism
has never yet existed socialism has
existed and them closer you get to a
government-run economy the worst things
get for all the talk about the socialist
economies and in Western Europe they are
not socialist economies they really are
not they're capitalist economies with
heavy taxation placed on top of them
even the taxation levels on businesses
are very low the reason that Denmark
continues I mean it was a thriving
Society they created a massive welfare
state on top of it that killed the
economy and now they're moving to the
right and looking to slash taxes
the fact is you cannot tact and spend
your way into prosperity that's not the
way business works
that's not the way pop prosperity works
well now before people say well the left
never identified with Venezuela I mean
the left never sided with Venezuela
let's just go through the let's quick
record on this let's go through the
what's record on Venezuela so let's
start with Michael Moore here's what
Michael Moore tweeted this is in
2012-2013 March 5th 2013 about Hugo
Chavez upon his death quote Hugo Chavez
declared the oil belong to the people he
used the oil to eliminate poverty to
eliminate 75% of extreme poverty provide
free health and education for all really
the ultimate place with no extreme
poverty how about the health care you
know the place where there have gloves
or soap yeah Michael Moore that guy was
seated at the 2004 Democratic National
Convention next to Jimmy Carter Jimmy
Carter by the way has also praised Lugo
Chavez when Hugo Chavez died Jimmy
Carter had this to say we find the
direct quote Jimmy Carter praised Chavez
is quote commitment to improving the
lives of his fellow countrymen adding
that he would be remembered for his bold
assertion of autonomy and independence
for Latin American governments and for
his formidable communication skills and
personal connections with supporters in
his country and abroad to me gave hope
and empowerment Eugene Robinson of the
Washington Post called Chavez quick and
popular Larry King called him hug lo the
AP homo fighter the Atlantic stated
quote passionate and charismatic Chavez
slipped comfortably into the role of
romantic Latin American revolutionary
championing the poor against an
unfeeling local oligarchy and its
imperial paymaster's today millions of
Venezuelans will weep tears of genuine
anguish and a passing ABC News and moon
Avicii on that he was revered by
Venezuela's poor who considered him one
of their own
the New York Times sounds it off calling
him a dreamer with a common touch an
enormous ambition all he had to do is
crush his advert area adversaries
destroy the economy destroy press
freedom
in the country no problem at all Joseph
Stiglitz Nobel prize-winning economist
who leans to the left he said this in
2007 quote venezuelan President Hugo
Chavez appears to have had success in
bringing health and education to the
people in the poor neighborhoods of
Caracas again now the most violent city
in the Western Hemisphere to those who
previously previously saw a few benefits
of the country's oil wealth it is not
only important to have sustainable
growth but to ensure the best
distribution of economic growth for the
benefit of all citizens
once you redistribute you cannot you
cannot hope to grow ok that's what
redistribution ISM does it destroys the
incentive for profit creation I want to
talk more about what the left has had to
say about this regime because they own
this Left owns Venezuela don't allow
Bernie Sanders to escape responsibility
for Venezuela Bernie Sanders believes in
the same principles as Chavez and
Nicolas Maduro he pretends he doesn't he
lies about it
the left lies about this routinely when
they say there's a leftist utopia the
leftist utopia looks a lot more like
Venezuela than it does like Denmark
because the bottom line is that even
Denmark is based on a capitalist system
that the left really doesn't like very
much they by the way even Denmark if it
didn't have the United States holding up
its military budget for years and years
and years and if they hadn't been using
capitalist corporate tax systems for
years and years and years would have
been in serious trouble look a lot more
like Greece than it would like Denmark
but before we get to any of that first I
want to say thank you to our friends
over at the u.s. CCA or the over the
weekend the Chicago trib reported that
56 people were wound at eleven of them
fatally but these are dangerous times
one of the kids who was killed was ten
year old Gustavo he was simply riding in
the car with his dad when he was
attacked well that's not the same thing
for a lot of us CCA members there was
one u.s. CCA member David whose young
sons were threatened by armed thugs
during a trip to the barbershop he was
forced to use his firearm to defend them
he killed one guy and he wounded the
other which is the way that you are
supposed to do it if you own a gun but
that didn't end your legal saga because
the fact is that the u.s. CCA then had
to step in and help guide David through
the aftermath there will be legal
consequences if you are on if you have
to use your firearm under any
circumstances u.s. CCA was there to
provide all of that u.s. CCA helps
insure you against what happens after
use your firearm training for using a
firearm get you the firearm this is
defend my family now calm to hear all
the shocking details on david's story
and see the live news footage that
captured the moment he was forced to
shoot
on tape while you're there you can
figure out how you two can protect your
family's future from the unthinkable
that's what defend my family now calm is
for defend my family now calm again you
wanna know how to defend your family and
you won't be insured for after you
defend your family because the last
thing you want is to spend three years
of your life tied up in court with
nobody to help you out that's what the
US ECA is for and we thank them for
their sponsorship defend my family now
calm okay so here are just a few of the
key figures on the left who have spent
years praising Lugo challenge here's
Jeremy Corbyn the leader of the Labour
Party in Great Britain we nearly won
election to the prime ministership of
Great Britain talking about Nicolas
Maduro a Jeremy Corbyn a good ricardo
dedicado mechanical chemical erm being
underage or more annoyed granted the
twenty bandura's muy triste and really
no one has me Lesley Machado more
session as we head of a lucha control is
Gareth and Arachne Afghanistan it can be
a no leader in struggling in the halogen
Erica negra contra that policy is
economic article Banco Europa IRRI
thought was another such an element of
the war Britain in the country little to
play except mnk during his life we
discussed many problems building
socialism in America most mature Honors
Program Associate is Moe Eva's programs
Mucha
contra control capitalism Oh agent a
well dreams right thank you for a coal
miners whole palace made of the car
bananas and mechanical kudos for the
miners rank a very handsome people right
now for most Canadians talking tonight
was really rather dictator of he's I
mean he's talking about socialism and
the glories of it with a dictator of
Venezuela Sean Penn that idiot praised
it praised to go Charles went down to
Venezuela and here he is in 2012 when
David Letterman talking about how
wonderful Lugo Chavez this evil dictator
was what was your impression of the guy
well I think if people have oil under
their ground they're called wacky I
found in very fascinating guy very you
know he's done
the moment incredible things for the 80%
of the people that are very poor there
but a fascinating character somebody I'm
writing about and yeah just a genius
Sean Penn Noam Chomsky great thought
leader of left he praised Allah Chavez
of course I'm significant role that he
also significant in helping to bring
about some form of unification of the
hemisphere and move towards freeing
themselves from Imperial control look he
was not the only ones happened in most
of the countries and its dramatic the
past 10 years I've seen a change of
actually historic significance this is
the first government everyone concedes
that gave the population a sense that of
empowerment that there's a government
for then fact if you look at a little
poll it gave them a sense of empowerment
this is what leftism looks like the left
owns Venezuela and now they're never
going to never heard of it
what does this Venezuela country you're
talking about never heard who Nicolas
meant what okay the left does this every
time okay when people say to the right
what are your ideal countries look like
what are your ideal economic systems
very often people like me will point to
places like Singapore right we'll talk
about places that have open trade places
that have attempted to lower taxes not
necessarily every aspect of their
culture is something that I want the
United States to Emily emulate but
economically free systems benefit we
don't like socialism and redistribution
ISM because inevitably once you take the
line of redistribution isn't far enough
you end up destroying the economy and if
you continue down that line and you
don't tack back to the center
you end up destroying it even more
honest leftists will say that leftism is
basically a dose against capitalism and
if you take it too far it'll kill the
patient but maybe you need a little bit
of it but that's not what the torrontés
leftist who really believe this stuff
believe that what Chavez did was great
and then their shots one that dose
killed the patient I want to talk about
more about this and then I want to get
to some of the stuff happening inside
the Trump administration in just a
minute for that I'm going to have to go
over to Daley wired.com $9.99 a month
gets you a subscription to Daley
wire.com that means you get the rest of
this show why it's video show so you get
to see it it means that you also get
Andrew Clavin still alive you get to see
that as well you also get to see the
brand-new Michael Nolt show which has
just started
I watched yesterday's episode and it was
as good as it can possibly be Michael
but it's actually pretty good it's
pretty funny you can check that out
Michael Mills show over at the a where
$9.99 $9.99 a month plus you get the
entire website ad free plus if you get
the annual subscription then you get
this magnificent incomparable
spectacular unparalleled tumbler leftist
here's hot or cold it has our logo upon
it is something you'll treasure all of
your days and when you die you'll pass
it on to your children will treasure it
all of theirs until one day it is found
in a cave by Charlton Heston next to a
screaming baby doll when the apes ruled
the world but it will survive you won't
but this will survive the apocalypse and
that will be your lasting mark on
civilizations that you'll have this mug
so in any case make sure that you go
over and get the annual subscription or
if you just want to if you just want to
listen later go over to iTunes or
SoundCloud and and make sure that you
subscribe leave us a review we always
appreciate it we are the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
all righty so the the as I say bottom
line is that the left loves this guy I
mean yeah I don't want two more actors
because you know actors are stupid but
Jesse Jackson ran for president he still
a prized character in the Democratic
Party here's Jesse Jackson praising Hugo
Chavez when he died
Hugo paired the hungry gooble elemento
ambiental you live to the poor el mucho
en el tatio la humility he raised the
hopes you have them realize the dreams
later used or accomplice us when yo so
today we do mourn
por lo tanto oh and in DNK diremos
because we lost a lot
yo somos por que hemos perdido mucho we
have a lot left pero todavía no scada
mucho mas stable government ago Vieira
at a delay and oddly transition una
transición or de nada we pray the
presence of our great nations que Nova
permit a response to esta gray nación
unison yay pronto jump on common ground
by the way Barack Obama once called will
Chavez harmless harmless
does that look honest you what's
happening in Venezuela and now the West
owns this don't let them forget it the
next time they say that a country is
engaging in the sort of revolutionary
experimentation on economics this is
going to lead to widespread prosperity
understand that the end result no matter
how you approach it
the end result is when you tack to the
left when tax you part of the left you
end up in Venezuela okay so in other
news more kind of silliness from the
White House so yesterday there was a
report there's a lawsuit that broke in
which a guy named Brad wheeler who is an
investigator he was investigating
supposedly the death of South rich and
he had a lawsuit suing a bunch of people
including at Gutowski whose guy who
funded him and in his lawsuits he
alleged that basically Fox News in the
White House
cooperated in order to push the South
Ridge story for those who don't remember
this is a conspiracy theory temperatures
a DNC staffer he was killed at 4:00 in
the morning on Washington DC Street and
there were accusations that he was
killed having something to do with the
fact that he the ID
not a fact the idea that he was leaking
information to WikiLeaks and maybe the
Democrats in likened killed him or some
such nonsense so Sarah how could we
Sanders at the White House when she's
asked about their symbolism we had
nothing to do with Seth rich stories of
this Dell nonsense is the president know
about the story pre-publication and
pitting ethnic slurs on the way
destruction is the president had no
knowledge of this story and it's
completely untrue that here the White
House involvement in this story and
beyond that this is ongoing litigation
and I'd refer you to the actual parties
involved which aren't the White House
okay so good for her okay that's good
news then it's followed up with somebody
asking ok so just front believe the
South Ridge conspiracy theory that the
leaks though the Russian leagues were
not actually Russian they were cetera
talking to WikiLeaks and here with Sarah
Huckabee Sanders answer very quickly on
separate the president who leave the
credit in about original Fox News
reported it's a treacherous response
wars over the least of DNC Gmail
squeaky-clean
I'm not sure Peter thanks guys we've got
a small business event coming up shortly
and hopefully you'll all tune in this
verse it's pretty amazing statement that
she's not sure what Trump believes about
the South Ridge conspiracy the reason
that's amazing is not because she
couldn't say that he doesn't believe it
you know that like maybe she's never
talked about it with him but this is the
inherent problem with having Trump as
your president you being his press
secretary it imagine you could easily
imagine a situation in which she went
out there and she said of course he
doesn't believe it that's it that's an
unsubstantiated theory and two minutes
later Trump gets on Twitter and he says
well maybe it happened a lot of people
are saying it happened they thought I
mean you could easily see him doing that
because he's done that over and over and
over again
perfect example yesterday you know
yesterday okay so flashback
there's the Donald Trump jr. meeting
with a bunch of Russian lawyers Russian
connected lawyers he's been promised
there's going to be some dirty Hillary
information and that the Russian
government will pledge their support
basically to Donald Trump he initiates
this meeting Jay Sekulow this is a few
days ago there's just a couple of weeks
ago he's on with Chris Cuomo and he has
asked so Donald Trump jr. if you recall
released a statement initially about the
meeting and he said we only discuss
Russian adoption we didn't discuss
anything having to do with the campaign
and that ended up not being true so the
original statement there were rumors
that had been drafted by Donald Trump
himself not by Trump jr. and the Jay
Sekulow was on TV a few weeks ago and
here is Jay Sekulow saying no Trump had
nothing to do
the statement let's focus on what the
president was aware of nothing he was
not aware of the meeting did not attend
the meeting and was only informed about
the emails very recently by his counsel
and he didn't have anything to do with
the statement that Don jr. put out that
was being worked on with his team that's
no that was the same that John jr. put
out you talk about yesterday's for us um
the one over the weekend that yeah the
president was reading without everyone
that was written know that was written
by Donald Trump jr. and and I'm sure
with in consultation with his lawyer
because everybody I was reporting that
the president okayed the statement well
they're incorrect the New York Times is
wrong yeah I know is that shocking that
sometimes I make a mistake oh I'm not
trying to be disparage I mean I what are
you coming back for Chris but he issues
a statement that was sane which I'm I
don't by the way I wasn't involved in
the statement drafting at all nor was
the president okay I mean I and again
he's saying the president was not
involved in the statement yesterday at
the White House Sarah W Sanders was
Donald Trump involved in the drafting of
the Trump jr. statement the statement
that Don jr. issued is true there's no
inaccuracy in the statement the
president weighed in is any father would
based on the limited information that he
had this is all discussion frankly of no
consequence
god no follow up loyal to the president
this is the problem if you're Sarah
Huckabee Sanders you don't know on a
day-to-day basis if you're going to be
undercut this has to stop from Trump but
it's not going to stop from Trump
because this is who Trump is yesterday
Trump came out and there was a boy scout
you know he spoke to the Boy Scouts and
we played the audio of it last week and
the video of it last week and it was
pretty ridiculous I mean he went out
there and basically did a campaign rally
in front a bunch of fifteen-year-old and
it was really quite hilarious and then
he said I was called by a leader of the
Boy Scouts who said it was the greatest
speech they'd ever heard the Boy Scouts
came out and said no we didn't in fact
we sort of said that the speech was
inappropriate when no one here called
him if so if you something about the Boy
Scouts makes it very difficult to be his
press secretary again it's not on Sarah
Huckabee Sanders it's just to point out
that whoever is the president's
representative is going to be in a bit
of trouble because you can't you can't
say things that any other person would
think we're normal because Trump might
undercut you and that leads to a serious
problem for the Trump administration
itself you could
a whole spate of questions day after day
the media going in there and asking
Sarah Huckabee Sanders does the
president believe that the moon is made
of green cheese and that the Wizard and
that the Wicked Witch of the West
surrounds it on her broom every evening
and Sarah Huckabee Sanders goes no of
course the president doesn't believe
that and then the next day Trump comes
Isis well I don't know maybe right and
the problem is that because she's
cautious about that she's going to have
to say I don't know the answer and then
the headline the media are going to run
is Trump doesn't know whether moon is
made of change that's what they're doing
on the rich thing this is why having an
unpredictable president or really an
unstable president when it comes to
these sorts of issues is really not
helpful in any way and it's why I'm very
skeptical you know we'll find out but
I'm very skeptical that they're putting
General John Kelly in charge of his
staff is going to help according to
endow Ski yesterday another one of
trumps tabled wonderful pics he was
saying that Kelly's the chief of staff
but he's not going to be chief of the
president Cory let's talk about general
Kelly what I you know you know him I
know him just very you know very much on
the surface I've never really spent any
time with them but by all accounts he
was a loyal implementer and enforcer of
the Trump agenda over at the Department
of Homeland Security I don't know how
would get anyone really frankly much
better at DHS and now he's in the West
Wing someone with very little political
experience or none now managing that
sometimes unmanageable place well is
there interesting look I think the
choice for Donald Trump President Trump
was a clear reflection of his desire to
move in a different direction and to put
a reset together but I think if you know
general Kelly secretary Kelly is going
to be successful which he is going to
learn very quickly and it's a phrase
that I have coined and I think people
understand is you have to let Trump be
Trump and you're not going to change the
president because for the last 40 years
he's been an unbelievably successful
business executive television executives
author you know real estate executive
and he doesn't want to change and that's
not what the American people voted for
they didn't vote have donald trump
change a voter for him to be himself and
what i think general kelly is going to
bring is the discipline to the staff
he's a chief of
stamp is not the cheek of the president
and the P is able to do his job which I
think he will which will be limiting the
backbiting and the infighting amongst
the individuals for serving inside the
administration that is a very very
important thing and put everybody on one
agenda which is a trump agenda
okay so again this is a big problem here
and it does remain a large problem for
the Trump administration Trump's gotta
lock it down it's about Trump it's not
about a staff it's not about people who
surround him at a certain point if you
as a human being I realizing that
everybody around you doesn't want to be
around you maybe it's not the people
around you who are the problem maybe
it's you and the president needs to
start thinking about that a little bit
more if you want to have a successful
administration okay and by the way I
think he's done a couple of things in
the last couple of days I mean I started
the show talking about his affirmative
action policy that's good stuff he's
doing the right thing on Venezuela they
released the Trump administration
released a statement yesterday in which
they condemned Maduro and they said that
the united states hold Maduro personally
responsible for the health and safety of
mr. Lopez mr. Ledesma and any other
seeds that's good I mean he's doing some
of the right things that can continue so
long as he contains his own it and
that's imperative okay time for some
things I like and then some things I
hate so things I like all week long
we've been paying tribute to the late
great Anthony Skinner Moochie the
greatest of all characters in the Trump
sava
thus far today's comparison to Anthony
Skinner mood she comes courtesy of Kevin
Williams in a National Review
he wrote a fantastic piece in which he
talked about how a lot of people who are
kind of followers our fans of Alec
Baldwin's speech from Glengarry Glen
Ross the famous always be closing speech
he says there's like a bunch of people
who think that this guy's the hero of
the film when in reality he's a jerk
right and that is Anthony scaramouche
it's almost impossible not to see Alec
Baldwin's performance here and think of
scaramouche a bloviating guy you know
over-the-top talking about how powerful
he is
because only one thing counts in this
life get them to sign on the line which
is dotted you hear me you confess a b c
a always BBC closing always be closing
always be closing
AI da attention interest decision action
attention do I have your attention
interest
are you interested I know you are
because it's or walk you close or you
hit the bricks decision have you made
your decision for Christ an action AI da
get out there you got the prospects
coming in you think they came in to get
out of the rain a guy don't walk on the
lot less he wants to by sitting out
there waiting to give you their money
but you wouldn't take it
and enough to take it okay so they're
one of the great speeches in the in film
history this isn't actually part of the
original play which I didn't know it was
written specifically for the movie Alec
Baldwin is only in the movie for this
five minute segment basically but but
the truth is that people who think that
this kind of stuff is real life are
wrong okay there's a whole group of
business people who think of themselves
as this hard-charging guy who's really
going to get things done because this is
how business not really how business
works the way that the successful
business actually works is by making
deals that are mutually beneficial for
the two sides not by scoring people the
people who tend to screw people a lot of
the people who have great image you know
like Trump and Skinner Meucci but aren't
necessarily the world's best business
people because they're not actually
providing a mutual benefit in in in
their dealings okay other things that I
like I just had to show you this catch
from MLB last night this is Austin
Jackson playing for the Detroit Tigers
or actually displaying for the sorry the
Cleveland Indians I believe against the
Boston Red Sox and he's going to make
one of the great catches you've ever
seen in centerfield this is just amazing
off the bat of Hanley Ramirez great
hitter to Drake Wichita there's a long
fly ball deep center field text in fact
he lived he's believable caps he flipped
into the bullpen did he hang on that's
the only question at this point he sure
did what a play by ahahahahaha that just
might be the play the year
Hanley ramírez is stunned
did you see how I'll endure jump after
his dumb jump over the fence with the
ball Austin Jackson can still go get
them with the best this might be the
best time play you'll ever see I'm
pretty amazing and the thing I love
about baseball is the Boston Red Sox
happening in Fenway Park the Boston Red
Sox fan gave him a standing ovation and
then after they showed that the the play
again on me on the big screen they've no
second standing ovations which is a
pretty cool thing okay time for a thing
that I hate so much so CNN ran what I
think is the world's stupidest headline
this is two days ago it has also
resulted in my most retweeted tweet ever
so here is the headline it's a picture
of what is clearly a woman who has had
hormone treatment with her husband a gay
man yeah trying to keep up with me here
it says transgender man assigned the
female gender at birth gives birth to a
healthy baby boy there are a couple of
problems with this headline one
transgender that's a woman that's a
biological woman who gave birth to a boy
right and then it gives birth to a
healthy baby boy
how dare CNN assign a sex to the baby
how dare they they say that that this
transgender man was assigned the female
gender birth you know just arbitrarily
randomly randomly how dare they said
this is a baby boy maybe the boy doesn't
want to be a point we don't know yet why
don't they just say gives birth to a
baby Ronda cages gives birth to a being
we don't know if the baby ignored so
identify as a human then once identifies
a cat do you know I don't know so I
treated it like and this made the rounds
is a big story ooh big story I tweeted
out after after this headline came out I
cheated out woman gives birth to baby
boy right that was my extra that was my
tweet that tweet now has I believe 96
thousand likes ninety to them is like a
trump tweet like 96 thousand likes
because that's obviously what this story
is like why is it a headline the
biological woman gave birth to a boy why
is that a headline at all it's only
because there's a biological woman who's
had some hormone treatments but hasn't
had any of her parts changed obviously I
mean it is a pretty amazing scam when
you come to think about it there's a gay
man is having sex with a woman who is
apparently a man so I guess
a really weird way of getting gay men to
marry women and have babies you divided
to what what their others I mean I would
also wonder when I tweeted out about
this that I wondered what this what this
woman's perspective was on abortion and
so I realized she was a transgender man
and therefore she can't speak about
pregnancy because men can't get it just
don't or none of it works so that's all
that's all confusing
okay well normally I would spend some
time deconstructing the culture but
we've come to the end of our time
together today so we'll have to come
back here tomorrow you'll have to come
back to mr. Shapiro's neighborhood and
when you come back we will have many
things to discuss including the big idea
of the week and the latest news I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]